comment valoriser les ordinateurs mise
au rebut du conseil départemental tout
simplement met en place plusieurs
filières de recyclage ainsi la direction
informatique du conseil départemental
depuis maintenant plusieurs années
mise sur une protection optimale de
l'environnement en évitant au maximum de
mettre à la poubelle des ordinateurs
usagés de la collectivité
il faut savoir que ce sont plus de 3100
son poste de travail qui sont mis à la
disposition des agents
ces ordinateurs tous les cinq ans
environ renouvelle à peu près un
cinquième du parc donc on a le matériel
qui est devenu obsolète au niveau de
l'utilisation des services mais qui par
contre peut être réutilisé et donc c'est
un matériel qu'on
en fait on essaye de réutiliser ce
matériel dans deux orientations
différentes
la première orientation c'est qu'on
travaille avec la ressourcerie qui est
une association d'insertion par
l'activité qui récupère ses équipements
qu'il est revalorisé et qui les revend à
un prix très modique à des écoles à
d'autres associations
ça c'est la première voie de
réutilisation un local a donc été
aménagé pour faciliter les différentes
étapes de ce recyclage avec un volet
très important de conditionnement
d'ordinateurs en direction de la grande
île opération donc avec les pays de la
zone notamment madagascar où on fournit
des équipements régulièrement pour
des universités pour la gendarmerie pour
des associations aussi malgaches dont on
scott mais les envois et pour qui on
envoie la ressourcerie joue un rôle très
important dans le recyclage des
ordinateurs ont leur donnant une
deuxième vie mais également permettant
aux personnes à faibles revenus de se
doter d'un ordinateur pour toute la
famille sont revendus à moindre coût à
des associations à des personnes
bénéficiant des minima sociaux à toute
personne car maintenant on a pu avoir
quand même un stock assez suffisant pour
pouvoir satisfaire
pas mal de personnes la ressourcerie
joue un rôle très important dans le
recyclage des ordinateurs ont leur
donnant une deuxième vie mais également
permettant personnes à faibles revenus
de se doter d'un ordinateur pour toute
la famille la ressourcerie qui existe
depuis 2012 qui a été créée par mc
réunion on peut actuellement douze
personnes qui sont en réinsertion qui
suivent des formations qualifiantes
on la ressent services et les quatre
fonctions c'est la collecte la
revalorisation et la redistribution avec
un cours à finalité
transmettre un petit peu à tout le monde
savoir qu'est ce qu'on peut faire en
matériel soit le conseil général par
rapport aux ordinateurs mais aussi avec
des palettes avec des d3e des machines à
laver etc
la ressourcerie qui existe depuis 2012
qui a été créée par bach réunion emploie
actuellement douze personnes qui sont en
réinsertion et qui suivent des
formations qualifiantes